après l'appel à la raison de
l'ambassadeur du gabon à l'onu c'est au
tour de celui de la côte d'ivoire de
mettre en garde contre les comportements
racistes que subissent certains
étudiants africains qui tentent de
quitter l'ukraine écoutez mon pays a
appris que des personnes d'origine
africaine fuyant la terreur qui s'abat
sur les graines sont l'objet de brimades
de traitement à relents racistes si ces
informations étaient avérées il aurait
des raisons de se poser des questions
légitimes sur cette attitude pour le
moins discriminatoire et inhumaine
c'est le lieu d'inviter les restos
tissant des pays amis qui s'adonnent à
ce comportement a fait preuve de plus de
retenue de tolérance et d'un surcroît
d'humanité dans ces moments de défi pour
toute la communauté internationale
au maroc